[Musik]
corona alarm an den schulen manche
bundesländer überlegen alle schulen zu
schließen ein krisentreffen hat bisher
keine gemeinsame linie gebracht
corona panik an den börsen der dax
bricht historisch ein besonders banken
und die luftfahrt machen sorge unter
beobachtung der verfassungsschutz sagt
dass flügel netzwerk in der ard um die
ecke ist eindeutig rechtsextremistisch
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers genannte in allen an
einem aufreibenden nachrichten tag mit
sehr vielen neuen informationen zum
corona virus auch die welt des sports
steht so gut wie still mehr hat nachher
christin unternehmen fast schon
stillstand in 15 minuten mehr genannt
wir beginnen heute mit der frage sollte
auch deutschland komplett seine schulen
schließen denn die lage wird sich
zuspitzen heute gab es bei uns den
fünften corona toten ärzte mahnen zur
eile
große menschenansammlungen zu verbieten
eine reihe anderer staaten haben die
schulen bereits geschlossen in
österreich etwa fällt der unterricht
flächendeckend aus für mindestens vier
wochen
die bundesländer sitzen dazu zusammen
und haben punkte zu klären die enorme
auswirkungen haben werden deutschland
hat über 10 millionen schüler florian a
noch sechs wochen bis zum schriftlichen
abitur das humboldt gymnasium in berlin
tegel am vormittag endspurt im
leistungskurs englisch
hier wollen sie alles daran setzen dass
die prüfungen nicht wegen corona
ausfallen müssen
sagen wir es ruhig so abitur first das
heißt wir würden den gesamten
spielbetrieb so ausrichten dass diese
prüfungen ebenfalls stattfinden können
doch müssen schulen und kitas
vorübergehend bundesweit schließen um
die ausbreitung des corona virus zu
verlangsamen
die antwort darauf entwickelt sich im
laufe des tages am mittag die
einschätzung der
bundesbildungsministerin
grundsätzlich halte ich persönlich es
für richtig den flächendeckenden
schulbetrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
aber natürlich ist klar dass wir jetzt
jeden tag die lage neu bewerten werden
und auch müssen die lage bewerten das
tun währenddessen auch die
ministerpräsidenten in berlin und
offenbaren nach ihrer konferenz
meinungsunterschiede
ich dachte es für bayern sagen ich
schließe nicht aus dass wir
schulschließungen haben werden dass wir
auch eine lösung für die kitas finden
werden andere verweisen auf die
nachteile von solchen maßnahmen wie
viele eltern sind dann plötzlich darauf
angewiesen zu hause zu bleiben können
nicht zum dienst gehen zum beispiel ins
krankenhaus als krankenschwester als
krankenpfleger als ärztin oder arzt
die nächste pressekonferenz anderthalb
stunden später die zuständigen
kultusminister der länder bereiten sich
auf das szenario geschlossener schulen
vor
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
ausschließen dass es zu weitreichenden
schulschließungen kommen kann wenn
prüfung nicht stattfinden können weil
schulen geschlossen sind werden diese
prüfungen nachgeholt ein tag bislang
ohne endgültige antwort noch beraten die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin im
kanzleramt und währenddessen sagen
experten jetzt muss beherzt gehandelt
werden nicht erst wenn es zu spät ist
theo koll beobachtet das ganze in berlin
theo wir wissen wir sind ein föderaler
staat aber das virus macht vor
bundesland grenzen nicht halt warum
gelingt es nicht eine einheitliche
regelung zu finden und ich glaube im
wesentlichen aus zwei gründen der erste
ist es die betroffenheit vom virus in
deutschland noch unterschiedlich
verteilt ist die kultusminister haben
das heute versucht in eine art formel zu
packen einheitliche reaktion auf
unterschiedliche bedingungen haben sie
gesagt habe
de facto heißt es erst einmal ein
föderaler flickenteppich und es kann
sein dass wir heute abend oder morgen
früh erfahren dass einzelne bundesländer
alle schulen schließen werden und andere
eben nicht
und der zweite grund ist es die
strategischen einschätzung auch
unterschiedlich sind also sind frühe und
einschneidende massnahmen besser oder
lösen sie eher übertriebene panik aus
und das sind dann genau die unterschiede
aus denen so ein flickenteppich geknüpft
wird
theo herzlichen dank dass
schulschließungen die es an einzelnen
orten jetzt schon gibt bedeuten für die
schüler für die lehrer aber auch für die
gesellschaft das zeigt jetzt eva
schiller unter quarantäne
seit dienstag ist pauls gymnasium im
stuttgarter norden geschlossen sein
klassenlehrer und vier mitschüler haben
sich infiziert
paul und seine schwester maya müssen
jetzt zu hause lernen die eltern
kontrollieren so gut es geht ob sie das
auch tun nebenbei diskutiert regine
becker mit ihrem chef versucht zu
arbeiten während unseres interviews dann
die nachricht das gymnasium bleibt in
den nächsten wochen geschlossen
jetzt habe ich hier zehn freundinnen
bekommen wie buchen wir die nächsten
tage werden wir den nächsten wochen
generell gilt nur im quarantäne fall
wird für eltern der lohn weitergezahlt
bei einer vorsorglichen corona kita oder
schulschließungen sind die eltern
verpflichtet für eine ersatzbetreuung
für ihre kinder zu sorgen dass der
arbeitgeber raus aber jeder kann
versuchen individuell mit seinem
arbeitgeber eine lösung zu finden zum
beispiel unbezahlter urlaub oder
überstunden abbummeln regine becker kann
im home office arbeiten am nachmittag
holt sie ihr drittes kind von der
grundschule die großeltern in die
betreuung einbinden viel zu riskant ich
bringe man dann was zu essen habe ich
schon gemacht ich stelle aber dann
wirklich an die tür hin ich rufe durchs
fenster hallo ich bin da weil ich nicht
weiß habe ich was und meine kinder sind
meine große meine eltern gar nicht
besuchen zwei kinder zu hause das dritte
geht zur schule
am nachmittag spielen alle gemeinsam wie
sinnvoll ist dass die beckers würden
sich wünschen dass alle schulen
geschlossen bleiben
zur sicherheit wenn die schulen
schließen hat das wir haben es gerade
gehört auch massive auswirkungen auf die
wirtschaft viele eltern werden ihre
arbeit nicht mehr oder nicht in vollem
umfang nachgehen können und ein weiteres
problem das auch viele unternehmen
zukommt schon am montag hatte die korona
angst die börsen auf talfahrt geschickt
heute kam es noch schlimmer viel
schlimmer
am ende eines panischen tages stand ein
minus von mehr als 12 prozent
sina mainitz für uns an der frankfurter
börse eine schwarze woche an den börsen
sina heute noch einmal ganz besonders
für wen wird das jetzt richtig brenzlig
er für fast alle branchen ganz besonders
hart ist es aber für banken hotels
restaurants und die luftfahrt donald
trump hat den einreise stopp von europa
in die usa verhängt das abschotten eines
ganzen wirtschaftsraumes ist extrem
belastend am parkett herrscht inzwischen
größte unsicherheit einen derartigen
absturz der kurse hat hier noch keiner
erlebt die menschen tätigen heute ihre
hamsterkäufe und bleiben morgen zu hause
das ist gift für die wirtschaft jetzt
werden steuererleichterungen und
konjunkturpakete gefordert die talfahrt
beim dax kommt
selbst die europäische zentralbank heute
nicht stoppen
sie greift der wirtschaft unter die arme
günstige kredite sollen an kleinere und
mittlere unternehmen vergeben werden
so sollen pleiten verhindert werden
allerdings haben wir heute hier gesehen
dass der börse diese maßnahmen nicht
ausreichen wann der tiefpunkt am
aktienmarkt erreicht sein wird das
konnte und wollte uns hier heute keiner
erzählen
danke dir sie schauen wir noch mal
genauer nach frankfurt zur ezb und ihren
besonderen schwierigkeiten anderer
notenbanken etwa in den usa und
großbritannien hatten ja mit schnellen
zinssenkungen auf die korona krise
reagiert das ist ein weg den die
europäische zentralbank nicht
einschlagen konnte liegen die zinsen
doch schon bei null prozent was ezb
chefin christine lagarde stattdessen tun
will sagt dominik löschmeister
alle augen waren heute auf sie gerichtet
welche antworten hat ezb-präsident in
christine lagarde auf die korona krise
in der finanzkrise hatte ihr vorgänger
draghi mit mutigen worten den euro
gerettet die märkte beruhigt doch die
ezb belässt die leitzinsen unverändert
ich will nicht die nummer zwei sein die
sagt was immer es braucht aber ich
möchte dass alle an diesem ziel arbeiten
die ezb will vor allem die banken
stützen die große sorge kredite könnten
ausfallen eine neue finanzkrise kommen
auf 120 milliarden euro wird das
anleihekaufprogramm der zentralbank
ausgeweitet reicht das selbe pulver
verschossen die kann die zinsen nicht
mehr senken da ist jetzt schluss mit
lustig sie kann jetzt dafür sorgen dass
eine finanzkrise und der bankriese
schuldenkrise nicht noch einmal passiert
christine lagarde sieht vor allem die
euro staaten in der pflicht mehr geld
auszugeben in zweifel mehr schulden zu
machen die steuern zu senken
unsere analyse sagt dass man
hauptsächlich mit fiskalischen mitteln
gegen die krise ankämpfen muss man kann
von keiner zentralbank verlangen dass
sie an erster stelle steht fast response
die spielräume der ezb-präsident denn in
der korona krise sind begrenzt
und derweil schließen immer mehr länder
ihre grenzen schotten sich ab auch
unsere nachbarländer wie tschechien
die hotels in spanien melden 0 neue
buchungen und vergleichen das mit einem
meteoriteneinschlag in italien mit
seiner großen zahl von corona fällen ist
die lage in den krankenhäusern speziell
im norden weiter dramatisch jetzt müssen
auch fast alle geschäfte landesweit zu
bleiben und der us-präsident hat die
europäer mit einem einreise band für die
usa belegt der gilt mit ausnahme von
großbritannien und hat weitreichende
folgen minuten leinhos
die usa sind alarmiert 37 corona tote
landesweit mehr als 1000 infizierte
viele opfer kommen aus diesem altenheim
im großraum seattle die schuld sucht der
präsident in europa die eu hat es
versäumt wie wir reisen aus china und
anderen risikogebieten zu beschränken
das ergebnis sind zahlreiche neue
infektionsherde in den usa verursacht
durch reisende aus europa konsequenz der
einreise stopp für bürger der eu
kritiker sehen darin trumps versuch von
eigenen versäumnissen abzulenken weil us
bundesbehörden nicht genügend corona
tests liefern konnten
italien kämpft weiter mit drastischen
mitteln gegen das virus sämtliche
restaurants cafés und geschäfte seit
heute geschlossen
ladenbesitzer verzweifeln wir sehen uns
der staat hilft das weiß man nicht so
eine situation habe ich noch nie erlebt
nur supermärkte und apotheken noch offen
inzwischen gibt es in italien mehr als
800 corona tote und weit über 12.000
infizierte und plötzlich auch spanien
dort sind die korona zahlen binnen 24
stunden rasant gestiegen 84 tote fast
eine verdopplung und rund 3.000
infizierte auch spaniens regierung ist
betroffen
gleichstellungsministerin monteiro hat
das virus alle regierungsmitglieder
werden nun auch corona getestet im
spanischen fußball sind alle ligaspiele
bis mindestens ende märz ausgesetzt und
die kicker von real madrid mit toni
kroos stehen unter quarantäne
grund im trainingszentrum wurde ein
sportler positiv auf corona getestet zu
den auswirkungen im sport nachher auch
der cdu parteitag wird verschoben und
damit auch die wahl eines neuen
cdu-vorsitzenden mehr zur corona krise
in einem zdf spezial direkt nach uns um
1920 wie weiter in deutschland und auf
den neuesten stand bleiben sie auch
online in einem live blog auf heute de
und in der heute app so viel zu diesem
thema und jetzt eine wichtige
entscheidung des verfassungsschutzes er
will den rechtsnationalen flügel der afg
künftig beobachten lassen
der galt ja schon länger als
verdachtsfall aber mit der neuen
einstufung als zitat erwiesen
rechtsextremistisch kann etwa observiert
oder mit v leuten gearbeitet werden den
flügel gibt es seit etwa fünf jahren
seine bekanntesten gesichter sind der
thüringer landesvorsitzende björn hocke
und der brandenburger fdp chef andreas
kalbitz etwa 7000 menschen sollen
insgesamt dazu gehören nicole diekmann
berichtet
die dresdner rede björn höcke bezeichnet
das holocaust-mahnmal in berlin als
denkmal der schande das kyffhäuser
treffen inszenierte einzug personen und
kultige elemente und enge kontakte zum
pga organisator bachmann unter anderem
vorbestraft wegen volksverhetzung der
flügel ab sofort voll im visier des
verfassungsschutzes zu einem voll
umfänglichen und schonungslosen lagebild
des rechtsextremismus gehört dass wir
rassistische agitation hass und hetze
auch durch parteien benennen die im
parlament vertreten sind heute teile ich
ihnen mit dass wir den flügel als
erwiesen extremistische bestrebungen
eingestuft haben
andreas kalbitz wird den flügel
gemeinsame türke an die furcht vieler in
seiner partei vor dem verlust von eher
bürgerlichen funktionären und wlan redet
er heute klein es geht glaube ich eher
um angst und panikmache um beamte zu
verunsichern die mitglied der kfd sind
und so einfach ist es nicht wie
herhalten banken und auch der die
anderen politischen gegner das gerne
hätten nämlich beamt herauszudrängen
insofern sind wir da gelassen ganz so
locker sehen fraktionschef gauland und
bundessprecher kogler das allerdings
offensichtlich nicht sie sagten heute
einen anberaumten pressetermin wieder
absteigen statt rückendeckung für den
flügel distanz statt solidarität bei den
grünen zustimmung zur entscheidung des
verfassungsschutzes doch sie fordern
noch mehr
solange die afg sich nicht vom flügel
trend ist diese gesamte partei
rechtsextrem zur gesamten partei wollte
sich der verfassungsschutz präsident
heute nicht äußern
und trotzdem ist eines klar von ihrem
ziel die bürgerliche mitte zu erreichen
ist die afg mit dem heutigen tag ein
ganzes stück weiter entfernt
für bundestagspräsident wolfgang
schäuble war ein scharfsinniger und
leidenschaftlicher liberaler burkhard
hirsch ist gestorben
gegen den großen lauschangriff gegen
staatliche eingriffe in die privatsphäre
für die bürgerrechte erhob der ehemalige
fdp innenminister von
nordrhein-westfalen jahrzehntelang seine
stimme
burkhard hirsch wurde 89 jahre alt
anselm stern
sein ganzes langes arbeitsleben kämpfte
er für die freiheit für bürger und
menschenrechte die rechte jedes
einzelnen sein thema als innenminister
in nordrhein westfalen als abgeordneter
und später auch als vizepräsident des
deutschen bundestages von anfang an
seine partei die fdp mit 9 10 trat er
ein
ich wollte endlich in einer gesellschaft
leben in der selber entscheiden was ich
denken darf denke bin was ich tun und
lassen will und wo ich meine freiheit
verwirklichen kann sagte burkhard hirsch
2016 zusammen mit dem früheren
bundesinnenminister gerhart baum seinen
engsten verbündeten seinem langjährigen
freund beide stehen für eine sozial
liberale fdp legten sich oft mit der
parteiführung an und sie klagten gegen
staatliche überwachung etwa gegen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung oder den großen
lauschangriff ein staat in dem alle
bürger verdächtig sind ist selber
verdächtig klar entschlossen überzeugt
so sagen viele habe burkhard hirsch
gekämpft für sein großes thema die
grundrechte der bürger tempo 100 auf
autobahnen und zwar auf allen was sich
viele in deutschland nur schwer
vorstellen können setzen die die
niederlande seit heute konsequent um
mit der einführung des landesweiten
tempolimits kämpft unser nachbarland
gegen den hohen stickoxidausstoß der die
eu grenzwerte erheblich übersteigt tempo
100 gilt unmittelbar nachdem die
schilder aufgestellt sind allerdings nur
tagsüber und damit sind wir beim sport
und auch der im zeichen von corona die
welt des sports christin steht so gut
wie still
hab vorhin schon gesagt fast stillstand
aber ein bisschen was gibt's noch
borussia dortmund hat den ersten
viertelfinal-einzug in der champions
league seit drei jahren verpasst nach
dem 2 1 im hinspiel kassierte der bvb im
leeren stadion bei paris st germain eine
bittere 0 2 niederlage für die gastgeber
eine genugtuung
spitzenfußball ohne stadionbesucher
offensichtlich auch keine lösung
1000 psg fans versammeln sich vor dem
prinzenpark feuern an und feiern nach
dem spiel die mannschaft dass der verein
seinen anhängern in den sozialen
netzwerken dafür dankt erntet auch
harsche kritik nehme hatte paris nach
einer di maria ecke in der 28 minute in
führung und auf viertelfinalkurs
gebracht anschließend einen torjubel von
dortmunds holland imitiert und damit
verhöhnt
kurz vor der halbzeit das 2 0 durch juan
bernat in der 89 minute geraten und lena
aneinander
rot für zahn- und sperre in der nächsten
saison für thomas tuchel und paris geht
die champions league reise weiter
vorerst das erste bundesliga spiel ohne
publikum endet mit einem sieg für
borussia mönchengladbach die
nachholpartie gegen den ersten fc köln
entscheidet nach flanke von emmvee
dieses eigentor von kölns mary in der 70
minute gladbach verbucht mit dem 2 1 den
fünfzigsten derby sieg und ist vor dem
spieltag tabellen vierter beim
zweitligisten hannover 96 gibt es einen
zweiten corona infizierten spieler die
gesamte profi mannschaft ist nun in
quarantäne
ungewohnte ruhe zieht ein rund um die
sportwelt so setzt zum beispiel die
nordamerikanische basketball profiliga
nba ihren spielbetrieb vorerst aus
vorzeitig beendet wurde heute die
skisprung saison und auch im biathlon
wird ist kein weltcup finale kommende
woche in oslo geben
die letzte station begann in kontiolahti
in finnland
dort feierte im sprint nach einer
perfekten schießleistung der norweger
johannes teenies boe seinen zehnten
saison erfolg mit gut 20 sekunden
vorsprung auf seinen dauer-rivalen dem
franzosen martin fourcade bester
deutscher benedikt doll als sechster und
down under soll nun auch der formel 1
auftakt in melbourne abgesagt werden
steht aber noch nicht ganz fest was für
zeiten christin vielen dank noch platz
nass damit sind wir beim wetter aber die
sonne kommt langsam auch wieder raus die
details gleich von pisten terry
ich empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit
dem kollegen claus kleber um 22 uhr er
hat fragen an bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder
danke für ihr interesse gern bis morgen
aber erstmal in allen einen sehr
angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schön kunde und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein neues tief kündigt sich
an oder es kommt von norden her bringt
neuen regen und teilweise schnee in den
mittelgebirgen mit schauen wir die nacht
und da sehen sie schon die vielen wolken
im nordwesten die allmählich südwärts
ziehen
der wind ist allerdings aus
südwestlichen richtungen ist kräftig an
der nordsee sogar stürmisch in der mitte
klart es auf und auch im süden gibt es
regen und schnee an den alpen
temperaturen sinken auf minus 1 grad im
vogtland hier also glätte angesagt 6
grad sind es im südosten und morgen
vormittag weiterhin viele wolken mit
regen und teilweise auch gewittern und
dazu auch sturmböen besonders in der
nähe von gewittern
der wind kommt generell aus
südwestlichen richtungen und ist stark
im süden da gibt es noch regen und
schnee an den alpen aber das lässt
allmählich nach schauen sie hier
da wird es allmählich freundlicher viel
sonne schauer und gewitter gibt es dann
im osten ebenfalls teils mit sturmböen
dazu temperaturen von sechs grad im
vogtland und 13 grad im südwesten
deutschlands
die kommenden tage werden allmählich
trockener samstag bis 12 grad und auch
mehr sonnenschein gibt es 17 am sonntag
18 am montag ein schöner abend